[Music]
hi i am adam krall veterinarian and
nutritionist for pioneer today i want to
talk to our cow calf producers about
weaning how we can do this successfully
to do this successfully we want to try
to make as few changes to this calf's
environment as possible
so
having a place where our calves can can
go and eat ahead of weaning that will be
where they were
eventually be weaned into
is is an ideal situation
the use of a creep gate to allow the
calves to to go into their own area
where they can be fed a supplemental
feed such as a commercial creep feed or
a feed with highly digestible fiber such
as soy hulls or soy health pellets is
really important
another thing that can make
weaning very successful is having a high
quality alfalfa to wean our calves onto
this should be an alfalfa that is
at least 20 protein
and at least 180 of relative feed
quality
it's important when we're looking for
alfalfa to start our calves on
that we really pay attention to relative
feed quality and not just relative feed
value
the big difference is relative feet
just quantifies the amount of fiber that
is in these alfalfa bales and the
relative feed quality
determines how digestible this fiber
actually is and this is really important
as
our calves brewman is not
as efficient as mature cow and so we
really want a highly digestible
forage to start our caps on for more
videos like this go to pioneer.com and
subscribe to our feed for thought video
series
that concludes this pioneer agronomy
video podcast visit our page on
pioneer.com and follow us on twitter and
facebook for more agronomy insights